[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday May 10th
the third day of my house hunt the Yeti
and I have seen 26 houses in the last
two days she throws my hat out the
window and goes out the door I'll get
another mother
or spend my money
the person on the five
every way
now I'm at the head
hey wait go back go back that a
treehouse yeah it is
you saw it house of the treehouse that's
awesome yeah I know it was it was pretty
cool it was a cool house hated a house
of any other really cool features it had
a pub room dude
you saw a house that had a tree house
and it had a bar downstairs where you
could have two different kinds of beer
on tap yeah it was pretty nice I guess
dude why didn't you buy that house well
cuz the Yeti was all like we need
bedrooms
[Music]
seriously Hank that's a lot of houses I
think I'm gonna have to fill in the rest
of this at the Indianapolis Airport
because we still have to do more house
hunts Hank I have great news or at the
very least potentially great news
Sara and I saw a house we really really
really liked and we put an offer on it
that means that it was like we told the
house we liked you and then we wrote
them a note that said do you like us
back please check one Yes No maybe and
now we're waiting for the house to write
us back specifically the house in the
form of its current owners we're very
nervous anyway Hank here's a quick tour
of the house that we may live in if they
like our offer
spins maimana do the last long time just
I moved them along
after way
[Music]
now I'm of the everday
they took me in the day with my back to
the wall and long-tongued mama was the
cause of it all I'll sweep in the woods
here in a hollow log for stay with you
will its treat me like a dog won't care
and I have to wait
the day
anyway Hank it's a great house in a
great neighborhood you can walk to this
quaint adorable little coffee shop
called Starbucks do you like it I hope
so because you're gonna have to come
visit us a lot because we got a guest
room just for you anyway Hank wish us
luck with the house and I'll see you
tomorrow